today i'm going to be speaking with
filmmaker and journalist daniel lombroso
whose debut feature white noise
is based on his four years reporting
inside the alt-right
and opened last year daniel so great to
talk to you today
thank you for having me on the show so
in the film
you uh spend time with at least some
folks that i know to some degree
i've interviewed richard spencer a few
years ago and it was sort of a
interesting experience which which we
can talk about i mean i guess first to
kind of set the stage
what was the goal here how did you get
into covering the alt-right and how did
you end up
um basically meeting a lot of these
people and spending time with them
so i was one of the first reporters in
the country to start covering the
alt-right right around when actually you
were putting out these really important
primers on the movement and i was
watching them at the time
if you go back to 2016 when trump was a
candidate the movement was not getting a
lot of attention and
i was a young reporter at the atlantic
at the time
and you know i just said to my editors
like there's this fiercely
anti-semitic racist movement that's
bubbling up online
at the time on reddit and obviously
4chan as well i had only graduated from
college a few years earlier so i saw
you know aspects of that on college
campuses already
and i just said to the editors of the
atlantic this is something we have to
pay attention to it's only growing in
strength
um a few months later i started covering
richard spencer before he was a
household name and i was the one who
actually caught a room full of people
breaking out into nazi salutes you might
remember that viral video at the time
yep and that was really important
because it clarified that
this wasn't just a group of edgy
conservatives like the way it was
covered and i think you also did a great
job of clarifying that at the time
this was fundamentally a white
nationalist movement and it needed to be
covered
you know with the utmost due diligence
and care
when charlottesville happened about
eight months later the atlantic
understood that this was only growing in
strength and they gave me the space to
produce a feature film so that's when it
really became a full-time project
when you look at uh your time
spent with these folks and i know i know
you've covered richard spencer you've
covered mike cernovich you've covered
lauren southern
and and many others um they're i'm
curious your thoughts on
whether we can make any more general
assessments of the goals of these folks
because
to some degree i feel like many of them
recognize that their goals at least as
stated are not likely to become a
reality anytime
soon and so that leads me to wonder
about
whether this is essentially a marketing
of some kind
marketing themselves pr a sense
essentially becoming known within a
movement and less less about actually
achieving the movement's goals
or whether or whatever i mean i guess
that's that's
i'll leave it there it's a great
question
i mean it really runs the gamut i think
fundamentally this is a violent movement
richard spencer who coined the term
alt-right
he believes in a white ethno state what
that might sound like a flashy word but
what it means is a country that has
let's say 90
white population the u.s is 63
white and declining every year i think
that's great we should live
not that we cheer for that but it's
great to have a multicultural country
where everyone gets along
you know to get to the 90 white
ethnostate we're talking about mass
deportations we're talking about ethnic
cleansing
those are fundamentally racist ideas but
then you get the other side of it and
white noise really is all about the
spectrum of the alt-right and how it
goes all the grifterism that's part of
it
you get a guy like mike cernovich who
you know is happy to benefit from the
racism and how it can help you build a
brand
and you see over the course of the film
that he's selling skincare products he's
selling pills
he's making money off of big parties and
like some
crappy bar in new york city there's
there's so much about it that's
opportunism it's celebrity it's vanity
so the motivations are mixed and i think
that's why people are having a lot of
having trouble sometimes making sense of
what happened wednesday they're saying
is this serious or is it larping
it can be both and i found that it was
both yeah i mean it seems like in a
country
of 331 million uh there's plenty of room
for
all of the above to be examples of it
and to still have plenty of everything
exactly and i think what needs to be
clear though is that even if you're
coming from it
as someone who's larping who's
cosplaying who's having their moment in
the sun
you're still adjacenting yourself to the
spencers to the oath keepers to these
people who
believe this is a white man's country
and i think that's
you know morally problematic and maybe
that will get you some more twitter
followers and some money but
it's not worth the coalition that you're
in one of the things that's come up in
the days since the january 6th uh
riotous insurrection is
uh some even people i i respect like for
example economist richard wolf who was
my college professor
and others have been sort of reducing
what took place last week to
economic oppression and the the natural
result of inequality and i respect a lot
of the folks that are saying this but i
think that these are
are sort of some of their less good
takes and i did a commentary about it
earlier on in today's program i'm
curious because
you you were in and observing a lot of
these movements
uh what what can we say about the degree
to which economic oppression plays a
role
not for people like spencer who i
believe is from a wealthy family
individually but
in the people that follow these
movements to what degree like
could it be that economic oppression is
what makes them liable to get sucked in
but is not really the focus of the
activism or what can we say about the
economic aspect
i think the economic anxiety argument is
nonsense no offense to
to the professor i mean most of the
people that i covered were
from upper middle class highly educated
they live in new york
dc los angeles all the scenes in my film
take place in liberal enclaves san
francisco
you know southern california dc many
others i mean that's where these
movements have strength and of course
they can't they attract foot soldiers
from
alabama and whatever but this is not
like your granddaddy's racism of people
in
you know in trailer parks like burning
crosses and of course there's some of
that iconography
but this is the leaders down to the
followers are really like
smart educated kids um you know who've
been
radicalized by these ideas and you ask
about how it happens it's not because
they're hit with high taxes and they
feel like it's it's tyrannical and they
just want a more libertarian state
maybe there are a few of those people i
met very few of them
what it really is is that these people
are selling you on a promise that
you might be a bored unemployed kid in
your mom's basement
but you're actually a descendant of a
crusader of a greek of a roman that you
could take part in this amazing
historical legacy
um and i think that's a really
intoxicating narrative to see that
you're not just
you know a dis you know a disaffected
kid with no sense of purpose in the
world you could take part in something
larger
and that's what they're really appealing
to is this sense of narrative kind of
the sense of purpose existential purpose
well when i've when i've interviewed
former kkk neo-nazi
types uh you know frank mink and scott
shepard and you know a lot of these
different interesting people
and those who have spent time with them
folks like daryl davis as an example
the thing that invariably comes up is
that they were pulled
into these movements from a very
particular
circumstance which almost always is
lack of connection to other people often
parents but not necessarily feeling
out of touch with anything that they
would call community
sometimes there's abuse psychological or
physical that's going on and
and for the most part they will they
will recognize these are the ones that
made it out right so it's a
self-selected group but
they will recognize that the ideology
could have almost been anything
from whoever kind of presented them with
empathy and connection and a place where
they could belong
can you talk about that a little bit in
the experiences you've had
researching and doing the film it's a
great point i mean when you're inside
the movement it feels like a subculture
that could be any kind of subculture
it's almost like they're internet
celebrities who happen to be racist and
of course
the racism is important but what you
notice immediately is the is
the commonalities the code of
communication they all dress the same
you know 20th century like hitler youth
style haircuts
many of richard spencer's followers wear
short shorts and they're all drinking
the same drinks like whiskey they're all
eating the same foods
there's all of these in-group jokes i
mean it's really a community it's a cult
like any other
and it i've done a lot of embedded
reporting and other types of
fundamentalist movements but any any
sort of community
and it resembles any sort of tight-knit
community where the community
is conferring importance onto the
followers giving them a sense of purpose
in the world
and i think if you track it to the
individual
all of them have a sense of resentment
they feel like that they haven't been
given their due in the world so
mike cernovich was an out-of-work lawyer
his first wife
was very successful she's she's a lawyer
at several
big tech companies and they got divorced
he took a lot of her money and
he took a lot of money in alimony which
is very you know
beta for the so-called alpha male um and
he felt really resentful that he never
really took off as a lawyer
and then he found a niche in this world
he became someone prestigious on the far
right
um you know mainstreaming everything
from pizzagate to that hillary had
parkinson's
he became a person of status and i think
that's what this can provide and
and the list goes on and on richard
spencer was an out-of-work journalist
never got any attention and then one day
trump ran was the gasoline that spencer
needed to start the engine and and
all of them especially the leadership
share that kind of story where
the movement gave them gave them a
purpose in the world not that this was
the most important thing you just said
but it just
kind of peaked my curiosity you say they
eat the same foods what foods are they
eating that that's
that's interesting um
you know there's there's a few funny
examples uh lauren southern who's one of
the three
characters in the film and i think
probably the most interesting her
her boyfriend at the time they've now
broken up we joked with a culinary white
supremacist because he told me he
refused to eat
quote non-european foods really so i
went
i i filmed them on a date once and he
wouldn't touch the ketchup because he
claimed ketchup
was originally derived from china from
the word ketsup or something
so he wouldn't touch the ketchup and we
ate it like a british pub in toronto
they ate
it's in the film and it's also an
article i wrote about lauren and that
section of the story went totally viral
on twitter because it's just absurd
yeah that's interesting like i wonder is
is brisket considered
white russian or jewish like would
brisket be acceptable i wonder where
they would come down on that
well jews are not part of the ethno
state and right
i i'm jewish and i was on a road trip
with with spencer to one of his shoots
and the car broke down once and we were
stuck in central florida and pitch black
at a gas station for a few hours
and i said richard like can i be a part
of your ethnic state
and he was like i'm sorry daniel but uh
it's not going to work
yeah well it's interesting you mentioned
that because when i had them on there
was this question of sort of like
you know the a lot of this idea of the
ethnostate is based on some fundamental
incompatibility
of these groups that just that like we
can kind of pretend to get along and he
said you and i could probably get
together and have a beer and there would
not be an
an obvious conflict in that particular
interaction
but at some bigger picture level there's
differences in values there's
differences in culture etc
uh and and i don't know if he this
interview was three and a half years ago
i don't know if it's he or others
of azil who have said that when jews
appear to be
integrated into american culture it's
because
they've essentially given up whatever
is core to them and are kind of adopting
the american thing there's kind of these
post hoc explanations but
you actually did the thing like you hung
around for a while
yeah and i think what happens i'm also
you know i'm jewish i'm also the
grandson of two holocaust survivors and
over time i would tell my subjects about
their terrible stories you know losing
most of their families
you know i think everyone makes
exceptions for people they like and the
honest truth is that they came to like
me they would text me in
vulnerable moments a lot of that you
know that stuff that was on the record
is in the story i wrote about lauren
you know they would make exceptions but
the truth is is that like the jew is and
always
has been a stand-in for any sort of
issue that we see in society so now
they're
the bankers that you know soros
obviously is something we use all the
time
he's the image of the parasite who's
pulling the strings from behind the
scenes
you know it's very common to hear them
talk about the rothschilds use to talk
about the zionist occupied government
which really isn't anything about israel
it's actually saying
that the us isn't is occupied by jews
behind the scenes
and you know i think there's so much dog
whistle anti-semitism that's all
around in this movement some of them
don't even realize that they're
purveying it and others are actively
doing it
and when it comes to the ethnostate you
know they're very very clear that
that this might come as a surprise to
most americans but that jews don't count
as white
in far-right contexts historically and
europe jews were not considered white
they were the original
other of course and um yeah and and you
know
richard to achieve his dream is willing
to accept any kind of
white person that wouldn't have
historically been seen white just
because he needs numbers so
he'll take russians he'll take southern
italians all the undesirables of the
past are fine
right but jews because of their unique
history would would not be part of it
in the limited time we have left based
on you all of your work and
knowledge and experience we're wondering
once trump goes
a lot of these folks that seem to have
only gotten involved in politics
because of trump and don't really care
about policy they're not really
conservatives in the traditional sense
do they remain engaged do they mostly go
back to being apolitical the way they
were before trump
i think they remain engaged and the
reason is this there's a huge
market opportunity for these ideas there
are millions of people who believe them
stop this deal the hashtag around you
know that the
election was you know supposedly stolen
from trump it's completely untrue
people are bringing hundreds of
thousands or even millions of dollars
behind that fraudulent idea
there are many individuals i'm not going
to call them out by name who've made a
lot of money from that
that lie and many other lies the market
opportunity will remain because there
are millions of resentful people
that believe that this is a white man's
country and believe that president trump
was wrongfully terminated by a bunch of
liberals and jews and democrats and as
long as you know there is a base that's
willing to eat up and pay for those
ideas
the individuals will still be there
ready to hawk them and make money off
them
all right we've been speaking with
daniel lombroso the film is white noise
what are all the places where people can
find the film daniel
uh it's on amazon prime um it's also on
itunes and we're doing a global
educational tour so if you're interested
in
having a dialogue around the film you
can reach out to me as well thanks
daniel i
really appreciate you telling us about
it today thanks so much for having me
that was great